the near future
and i want to be in a position where my
business model is not
opening uh 1000 locations and burning
billions of dollars annually
i want to reach a point where this is
starting to print money before we go to
national scale in the us
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lumitec
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance oppos labs synergy global
hillel at stanford leap birthright excel
serena partners and in media partnership
with c-tech
welcome to another episode of 20-minute
leaders this one is going to be amazing
we're going to be talking about drone
deliveries
from somebody who sent a spaceship to
the moon literally
meet yariv bash the co-founder and ceo
of flytrax and founder of space iel
erief bosch is the ceo and co-founder of
flytrax a drone technology company
providing comprehensive autonomous drone
delivery solutions that enable any
business from small businesses to
e-commerce giants to integrate instant
autonomous drone delivery into their
offering flytrax is an end-to-end drone
logistics solution spearheading the
drone revolution prior to flight tracks
derive was the founder and ceo of space
iel a 100 million dollar israeli
non-profit organization that attempted
to land bereshit the first private
interplenary robot mission on the moon
yaris bash the ceo of flytrax thank you
so much for joining me how are you today
thank you michael uh you know
as usual i'm great as usual how are you
doing i'm doing fantastic thank you so
many exciting things happening with
flytrax uh such an honor to be part of
the journey and to see you know the
future unfolding before our eyes i i
think about flight tricks all the time
and you know the picture behind you i
think is a you know great ode to to the
amazing things that you're doing and
already operating you know in production
in the united states delivering food you
know across houses with some really
exciting milestones achieved over the
last recent while with with an
incredible fundraising uh round as well
as some incredible authorization from
the faa to be able to to fly the drones
at a much greater capacity than before
and a really monumental achievement for
the industry as a whole so
i'd love to spend these 20 minutes
understanding a little bit better what's
happening with flytrax and what's
happening with the drone delivery market
today in the beginning of 2022
it looks like things are progressing
nicely uh we've been in this business
for
quite a while now eight years and when
we started people were like wow drone
deliveries that's gonna be you know
that's in the distant future
uh but right now we're already starting
to see the you know initial commercial
operations both in the us and in other
areas around the world and we think that
we're gonna see that starting to expand
pretty rapidly in the next year or two
so it's it's actually happening
so take me back a little bit to the
challenges of the drone delivery market
because it's really complicated concept
that one that is you know on one hand
revolutionizing consumer behavior on the
other hand it's infinitely complex in
order to get us there so so what's
happening
so i like to uh uh
give an example from the medical world
and you know you can order a few
chemicals online
go to a high school lab
and create something
but from there to certifying that thing
as a
uh medicine
it's a very long journey and it's the
same with drones i mean we can you know
people tell me eye your doors are pretty
horrible they can only fly a few miles
away
and carry three kilograms or six and a
half pounds
here are drones that can carry 20
kilograms to 100 kilometers but it
doesn't really matter i can produce such
a drone in my lab in our labs in a week
or so
the uh the hard part is not
attaching the the carbon parts together
the health part is certifying a
commercial airplane
and when it comes to that we're nearing
the end of the of a very long journey
and in 2022 we are going to see the
first few companies including flight x
with
certified certified commercial unmanned
airplanes flying above our heads and so
we're getting there pretty fast so so in
order for us to understand where you're
at now and why these two announcements
that you've made recently are so
monumental take me back a little bit
into this long incredible journey of fly
tracks you know just in in bits and
pieces just so we have context as to why
it really is so monumental where we're
at today
so basically until now
every commercial
uh pilot that you've seen especially
with drone deliveries was pretty much
very much limited anywhere in around the
world uh it's mostly uh about flying to
a few houses for a few days not flying
above people
it's it was very limited because it was
based on waivers and exemptions
uh around the the current regulatory
framework which is very limited
uh because the uh
aviation authorities anywhere around the
world
they're not really you know looking at
your drone or your airplane they're just
you know doing a
minimal certification for the operator
usually a few days and you're good to go
and you can buy a drone from china you
can assemble it in your backyard nobody
inspects it it's not really an airplane
so all approvals were very much well
pretty much limited
now uh back in 2018 19 the fa said okay
we're approaching
the real actual
very up you know complex drone uh
commercial dawn operations such as dawn
deliveries and we have to build a
framework for that
and that's where what we've been doing
since basically 2018 working with the
faa with the federal aviation
administration on basically certifying
our system as if it was a commercial
airplane and that's a very different
process than you know
a few days of training and you're good
to go but
because it's such a lengthy and rigorous
process
the
the approvals that you can get are
basically like in a commercial airplane
uh and it's not a zero to one as we're
nearing the end of that process we're
already starting to get approval still
waivers and exemptions it's still not a
blanket
for operations uh national operations
but we are getting approvals that you
can basically cannot get
with a you know off-the-shelf drone or
something just you've just you know
built in your backyard
or in a in a lab
it's the kind of approvals that signal
to the market
and to fly tracks
that we're on the right path
towards the uh the large-scale approval
so i i think it's hard for an outsider
like myself to you know to really
understand the the complex process it is
to get this faa approval but you know so
just for the context you know your your
team that is considerably smaller than a
lot of your competitors right team
that's that's you know based in tel aviv
working with the united states faa
authorities to to do this you know just
paint me a little bit of a picture about
what this is like for you as the ceo to
lead through this endeavor and you're
standing alongside giants like amazon
and google and you're right there with
them getting those same approvals
so i think the first thing was to get
into the mindset of
of the faa and it's very different than
you know working with anyone in israel
for instance it's a very different
mindset you have to be you know
as strict as possible because that's how
you're measured
and
you can't bluff and you have to do
everything by the book and that's okay
uh this is the big game and if you want
to play in the big game you have to
follow those rules
and we basically built a whole
regulatory team here in israel from
scratch working with the faa
and we're talking about thousands of
pages of manuals
from our maintenance method or flight
manual or concept of operations
it's really uh we we've
more than a year ago we printed out all
the documentation it was you know
two thousand dollars you showed it to me
when i came it's incredible
it looks like the whole harry potter
because put together
well that's how it works in aviation you
cannot bluff that yeah it has to be
uh it's commercial aviation it's it's
it's
i think it's tougher than you know even
medical approvals there are less
aviation companies there are medical
companies so uh
it's hard
but if you follow the rules and you know
uh you realize that this is a marathon
this is not a sprint
then
you can make it to the other side
hopefully so
the end of 2021 we're entering now 2022
some incredible milestones that are
pretty significant for the way that
flytrucks is now positioned
from a company that is attempting to
prove the viability of commercializing
drone delivery to a company that is now
and it's starting its growth stage and
actually going and doing it and and
watching you know the the fruits of of
of their hard work what are these two
things that happen recently and why are
they so monumental to what's happening
so basically we
we've received an approval from the faa
to fly in all three locations up to one
mile away
which allows us to start
making you know deliveries to uh
almost two orders of magnitude more
customers than uh until now we can now
basically we've got three stations
walking every day in north carolina
uh and we can service up to almost 10
000 families in those locations
and that's you know that's already
something that's working it's not a uh
a very limited pilot we've got customers
that are dependent on us they want to
get the hamburger
or the
pizza delivered and when they're not
getting it on time they're frustrated
and we're starting to see actual
traction actual commercial traction it's
still the early days we still have a lot
to learn
uh it's still just scratching the
potential in each one of those stations
because once you go for instance from
one mile to two mile you
basically
quadruple the size that you can service
in the number of families so it's it's
we're still just sketching the surface
but it's already you know happening on a
daily basis
uh
just you know the uh the evening of the
new years was i think the uh
the peak day for us we we actually
closed earlier than usual because of new
year's eve but i think that was the uh
the best day in terms of the deliveries
performed
so you know it's going from a company
that does regulations and and mostly
technology to a company that handles
marketing b2c
customer success
it's a very different company
but you know it's another challenge and
we love challenges so i i love it
and obviously you know
2021 has seen the growth of of some
incredible companies in the delivery
space a lot of them offering 10 15
minutes on foot you know or by bike
grocery delivery but you know a lot of
the things that i keep thinking about is
okay how you know where is the where is
the moat of these companies and how do
how can we really tell
you know who is here to stay and who's
not and where's the technology lie and
where is the differentiation and
obviously i think
how many years do would you say that you
were working on the regulation and the
technology side before going to the
commercialization
so it's awfully four to five years and
it's not going to get easier regulations
are only going to get harder and it's
not like we're paving the way i mean
we'll just
uh we're going into the uh
the regular type certification process
of the faa so it doesn't matter if your
flight tax from tel aviv or boeing from
seattle
it takes you four to five years even if
it's your 20th airplane
uh but you touched about an interesting
point uh you've mentioned all those you
know 15 to 20 minute grocery deliveries
but we have to realize that at the end
all those companies are working on a
niche market in the us
most of the us population is in the
suburbs and all those companies are
basically working in
densely populated areas in major cities
but in the us that's that's the you know
the smaller smaller market the bigger
one is the suburbs and over there those
services just you know it does make
sense for them to walk the population
density isn't
isn't big enough isn't you know
share with me a little bit more that
because i think this is a surprising
fact that also caught me by surprise
when i learned it the first time when i
think of the us i think new york san
francisco austin texas what you know
what is the real us from now
geographical and you know um you know
transportational perspective
so basically uh most of the u.s roughly
two-thirds of the population
live in private houses in the suburbs
we're talking about more than 80 million
backyards
and that's that's where the major market
is at
and until today most of those companies
have been focused on on
highly populated areas because that's
where the unit economy of using humans
work you can use you know you can
optimize the service you can pick up a
few others your couriers can use bikes
or walk by foot but once you go to the
suburbs
you cannot optimize because the uh
all the restaurants are spread too thin
yeah you have to use a car your couriers
have to use the car so the insurance
rates
and you know maintenance the gas
everything cost a lot more and that's
where the the model for
uh you know typica for a typical
on-demand service just breaks down right
uh and using drones that's you know i'm
not the best expert user experience for
customers in apartment buildings
but i am the best user experience for
the major part of the us which is the
the suburbs right and and honestly you
know i'm walking around tel aviv and i
can already picture kika rabin with a
place where the drones are putting in
the food so but but we'll leave that for
a conversation in a few years uh
the second big announcement
was their your most recent financing
which i think speaks also to your your
growth stage and moving from the
regulation regulation now to also
commercialization what was happening
over there
uh so we've just announced the 40
million dollar round which brings the
the total amount raised until now by
flight tax to uh 60 million dollars
and the goal of this round is to
actually start
deploying stations and to start showing
i i won't say profits but to start
showing how we can break even in those
stations
so which is you know the holy grail for
every on-demand company in the world
basically and the goal for us is to show
that this is not something you know i'm
not i want to show that this is
in the near future
and i want to be in a position where my
business model is not
opening 1000 locations and burning
billions of dollars annually
i want to reach a point where this is
starting to print money before we go
to national scale in the us
it's uh it's not an easy goal
but we want to reach you know we want to
be near nearing that
that position where it's just you know
tell me you know tell me i'll tell you
how many stations i want to open and
you'll tell me how much money you can
give us to do that so uh
it's gonna take about a year to two to
reach that that's that point but we're
uh
already starting to uh
to focus as a company on that so what is
that like switching the hats from you
from your if the maker the technologist
that that is creating these these
incredible drones and is getting faa
approval as if he's the ceo of boeing
right now because you're you are doing
the same things as boeing is doing and
all of a sudden now it's yariv the
businessman trying to optimize the
united economics and prove to the world
that this is a viable business that can
print money how do you balance those two
hats
well we've always had that in the back
of our heads so uh our door for instance
they're very crappy if you look at you
know the technical specs of our drones
compared to others they have the
shortest distance
but they were built in a way
to uh justify a five dollar bolito
delivery you cannot perform on demand
delivery with a bmw or a shiny brand new
tesla
it requires a different kind of vehicle
for those kind of deliveries and that
was always in our in the back of our
heads
as we designed the drones and the entire
system the entire system is built for
recurring
b2c deliveries with minimally trained
operators just you know doing the
minimally uh
the minimal amount of actions needed to
operate the system so it was always in
the back of our minds but and now it's
time to prove that it works on uh
increasing scales
uh
anything that's related to b2c in
marketing that's you know
it hasn't been in our focus it's
becoming our focus these days new kpis
new metrics
it's uh
you know it's it's refreshing and put it
that way we're
up for the challenge and we're actually
happy to uh
it's not a pivot but to uh to expand the
horizons and put it that way
what is the single thing you're most
excited about you know moving forward
you're entering 2022
running this incredible company
achieving things that so many have tried
and and i'm personally so so honored and
excited to be a such a small part of it
but i'm still so excited about it so
what are you most excited about
uh making the delivery seeing the
customers responses
uh but you know we we get like videos
that people post on tick tock facebook
linkedin
of happy customers and it's it's
it's you know seeing it in action every
day that's incredible experience
i get a report we all get a report every
day of you know the uh
uh all the comments of every user what
they liked what they didn't like
so
just make sing it in action every day
that's the the fun part of the system
after working on it for so many years in
the uh
just in the field without actual
customers
uh so it's it's very uh
it's pretty cool and now for us the
exciting part is just growing the amount
of deliveries and families that we can
service
and basically writing the book on
how do you open a station how do you
market it
how to get to as many people and make
them older as much as possible
just creating a service that people love
and like to use almost daily
yeah
this is so inspiring and i can only
imagine
what it's like working so hard for four
or five years on on this incredible
technology and regulation side of things
and all of us and now being able to
commercialize it and seeing the
responses from the customers and so best
of luck in 2022 i can't wait to continue
following flight tracks and seeing how
you're literally revolutionizing
consumer behavior at such a great scale
and it's going to be incredible
thank you very much and best of luck
thank you michael uh hopefully i will be
able to deliver to uh
to your apartment or house as well in
the uh next year or two wonderful
[Music]